hey guys it's me Gary Vaynerchuk the
reason I'm making this video or I don't
know if the rocks audio yet is because
the rock missed his flight and had not
missed his flight we wouldn't have audio
issues we wouldn't have episode 24
coming out when episode 32 is coming out
it wouldn't be a [ __ ] but it was
and that's what happened dee Ruxin
experienced with his traveling he
thought that he could have his ticket on
his app but when you fly international
you need to print it out he didn't
understand that and even though he
taxied for quite a while
and I said plenty of time to make the
flight unfortunate all his inexperience
cost him and inexperience is dangerous
at times so just like for about 10 hours
and did about 4 hours of work on email
caught up with a bunch of you
do you rock missus flight that was
hustling about some of you
-
day in and out land
the hotel shower daily events and go
back to the airport
last name Vaynerchuk for you that's
Vaynerchuk right here that's me I felt
it I felt it
so many people in this room live their
lives one way but they mark it a
completely different way right one of
the things that bothers me the most
especially the homework you know these
21 hour traveling days allow you to
catch up on a lot of work and on the way
here I paid attention to a lot of the
people in this room that have been
tweeting or facebooking or emailing me
that they were gonna be here and I took
advantage and was able to do three or
four hours of research to really pay
attention to what some of you guys are
doing in this room and to be very honest
with you and I and I apologize I didn't
want to come to Sydney to Raz but to be
very honest with you the far majority
people in this room that are marketing
are marketing in their best interest and
not in their consumers best interest the
lack of patience the lack of content
that has anything to do with other than
what you want them to do is quite
stunning and would be a very quick
indicator to me that the return on the
investment is not as great as you'd like
it to be because you default into caring
about yourself first a lot of you've
consumed my stuff you've heard my spiel
I'm a big believer that the people that
win deploy more value than they asked
for in return
that entire [ __ ] business is built on
telling people how to fix things they
suck at when they can't maximize it
that's the truth
way too many people can't get there it
is against everything you hear from
everybody I get it I understand how I
sit on this island very by myself in the
ecosystem but [ __ ] man let me say this
think about the thousand people that are
the most famous and successful in the
world and they all have only one thing
in common they [ __ ] hunted everything
besides that one talent and spent every
[ __ ] minute in their lives on that
one talent what the disconnect is is
that people want something to be
happening or don't want something to be
happening versus respecting what's
happened people don't wanna learn
snapchat it's another thing to learn
yeah they don't wanna learn and it's
confused and compared to the others
probably and so and so that's what I do
I just
I'm completely unemotional like it just
it is what it is
yeah first of all if I could wish I'd
anything for anybody would be health to
them in their family if I give a wish
the second thing it would be
self-awareness because it is the
prerequisite to a lot of happiness but
third would be for you guys to even feel
for 15 seconds what it feels like for
people to want to take your selfie with
you or have you sign a book you know my
mom coddled me a lot as a kid and gave
me a lot of compliments and I really
truly believe that I live a public
Lights because I want to replicate that
love feeling and and that's what you
guys did for me today and so it's I'll
fly anywhere for twenty-one hours to get
this kind of vibe back